eine seltsame ruinenlandschaft mit einer
dunklen geschichte
alles deute darauf hin dass hier jemand
gegen seinen willen aus haben musste
ein gefängnis in west virginia in dem
einige der schlimmsten verbrecher der
usa einsetzen die zustände wurden mit
jedem tag schlimmer bis es irgendwann
nicht mehr ging
ein einzigartiger bau der die
aufbruchstimmung im postrevolutionären
kuba verkörpert das war fidel castros
vision für die zukunft er wollte das
projekt in kürzester zeit umsetzen aber
das politische klima veränderte sich
rasant
und ein bergwerk das lange zeit zu den
produktivsten großbritanniens gehört
das war einst eine florierende anlage
aber irgendwas ging hier ziemlich
schnell ziemlich schief
zerfallende bauten ruinen aus
vergangener zeit einst mühsam erschaffen
heute nur noch schatten ihrer selbst
zeigt ihre geheimnisse zu lüften
[Musik]
im us-bundesstaat west virginia steht
ein monumentaler bau der an eine festung
erinnert
[Musik]
wenn man sich den über sieben meter
hohen mauern nähert ist das schon sehr
eindrucksvoll
gleichzeitig hat man das gefühl hier
nicht willkommen zu sein
das gebäude sieht ein bisschen so aus
wie ein europäisches schloss wie ein
düsterer und stark befestigter palast
wer hofft hier ein verwunschenes
märchenschloss zu finden wird enttäuscht
auch drinnen ist nicht sofort klar was
das ist es gibt eine kantine mit
bemalten wänden und oben findet man
einen zahnarztstuhl und medizinische
apparaturen etwas düsteres umgibt diesen
ort
[Musik]
tatsächlich saßen hier einst die
gefährlichsten verbrecher der usa
manche glauben sogar dass ihre geister
noch immer in den gemäuern spucken
wenn man weiter rein geht fallen einem
graffiti auf verrostete eisengitter
abblätternde farbe einen beschleicht das
dumpfe gefühl dass dort schreckliche
dinge passiert sind
das war offensichtlich kein ponyhof
heute fällt alles auseinander und
vergammelt was das gefühl der
trostlosigkeit nur noch verstärkt
warum ist dieser ort bis heute
berüchtigt
[Musik]
kennt die dunkle vergangenheit der
anlage
dies war einer der schlimmsten orte auf
der welt noch heute ist er bekannt für
die gräueltaten wie hier begangen wurden
das gebäude stammt aus den späten
neunzehnten jahrhundert damals kommt es
in den neu gegründeten us bundesstaat
west virginia zu einer reihe von
gefängnis ausbrechen um weitere vorfälle
zu verhindern wird das
strafvollzugssystem reformiert
neun insassen hatten sich einfach aus
dem staub gemacht und waren entkommen
das hat gezeigt dass man höhere
sicherheitsstandards brauchte um so
etwas zu verhindern
die lösung ist das west virginia
statements eines der brutalsten
gefängnisse in der geschichte der usa
es wurde gebaut um die gefährlichsten
verbrecher einzusperren
es sollte eine festung sein aus der es
kein entkommen gab
im zwanzigsten jahrhundert steigt die
zahl der verbrechen enorm an das
gefängnis steht nun vor ungeahnten
problemen
immer mehr menschen wurden für immer
schlimmere verbrechen verurteilt
das gefängnis war für einige hundert
insassen ausgelegt doch am ende saßen
mehr als 2001 dadurch häuften sich die
gewaltausbrüche
um die gewalt einzudämmen werden
einzelne gefängnistrakt abgetrennt in
diesem zellenblock haben sich insassen
gegenseitig abgeschlachtet es war der
gefährlichste bereich in der ganzen
anstalt man nannte ihn allemal wie das
vor in texas denn wer hier drin landete
glaubte nicht daran jemals lebend wieder
herauszukommen mindestens 22 stunden am
tag waren die häftlinge in solchen zwei
quadratmeter zellen eingesperrt sind
absolut winzig
doch die gefangenen wegzusperren setzte
gewalt kein ende
in diesem zellenblock ging es ums nackte
überleben und überleben hieß sich zu
bewaffnen die gefangenen brachen mit
teilstücke aus den türen oder kohlen und
schafften das metall dann am betonboden
noch heute sieht man überall dort
kratzspuren wo wahrscheinlich ein
insasse aus einem stumpfen stück metall
ein tödliches messer gemacht hat
und die insassen machen sich nicht nur
gegenseitig das leben zur hölle
gent hat neun jahre als wärter in der
haftanstalt gearbeitet
man hatte eine untersuchung durchgeführt
um herauszufinden wie hart es hier drin
wirklich wahr dafür hing man überall
thermometer hin die insassen brachen die
dinge auf und versuchten das quecksilber
in meinen kaffee zu mischen um mich zu
vergiften zum glück habe ich das
rechtzeitig bemerkt hier verging kein
tag an dem ich nicht angst um mein leben
hatte
die schrecken dieser zeit stecken sind
noch immer in den knochen
einige sachen wird man nicht mehr los
wenn du einen typen mit einer zwölf kilo
platte in der stirn siehst oder eine 30
zentimeter lange eisenstange die durchs
auge bis ins gehirn dringt und hinten
wieder raus kommt oder wenn ein typ
feuer fängt und seine haut verbrennt man
stumpft ab um das ganze zu überstehen
trotz all der gräueltaten wird das
gefängnis zu einer öffentlichen
attraktion
94 verurteilte schwerverbrecher wurden
hier im sogenannten des haus also todes
haus hingerichtet
die hinrichtungen waren öffentlich und
manche leute reisten von weit her an es
gab eintrittskarten ganze familien kamen
mit ihren kindern und picknickten
seelenruhig dabei
während das dvs eine geschmacklose
horror show für die massen bietet
floriert das organisierte verbrechen im
untergeschoss
da unten gab es einen unbeaufsichtigten
raum den alle scheck nannten zucker bude
die wachen hatten regelrecht angst da
runterzugehen weil das furchtbare dinge
vor sich gingen manche insassen fühlten
sich sowohl im keller dass sie darum
warten dorthin verlegt zu werden denn
dort gab es drogen gewalt und gangs
das west virginias state and we weckt
auch das interesse eines der
berüchtigsten verbrecher in den usa ein
mann der eine ganz persönliche
verbindung zu dem gefängnis hat ein
ende der dreißiger jahre wurde eine frau
namens catherine maddox zu einer
haftstrafe hier im gefängnis verurteilt
sie hatte einen kleinen sohn charlie
maddox der seine mutter im gefängnis
besuchte und dieser junge wurde später
bekannt als charles manson
im märz 1983 erhält der
gefängnisdirektor einen brief nachdem
charles manson zwölf jahre seiner
lebenslangen haft wegen siebenfachen
mordes abgesessen hat bittet er darum
nach west virginia verlegt zu werden
die behörden lehnten natürlich ab und
der gefängnisdirektor schrieb zurück
dass er die hölle zu frieren würde heißt
dass charles manson nach west virginia
kam
doch auch ohne charles manson hat das
gefängnis probleme seinem auftrag
gerecht zu werden
das west virginia state penny chenery
war als festung konzipiert wurden aus
der es kein entkommen geben sollte aber
das ist noch lange nicht dass wirklich
niemand fliehen konnte
im november
1979 kpc den größten massenausbruch in
der geschichte der haftanstalt 15
insassen hatten eine waffe ins gefängnis
geschmuggelt nahmen einen bart als
geisel gelangten so ins kontrollzentrum
und marschierten durch die forderte
heraus die stadtbewohner hatten große
angst
bei der anschließenden schießerei
gekommen ein polizist und ein
strafgefangener ums leben die 14 übrigen
flüchtigen werden später gefasst der
ausbruch ist nur einer von mehr als 200
in der geschichte des west virginia
statement juni
die insassen machten witze darüber wie
leicht es war aus dem gefängnis
auszubrechen
die idee einer ausbruchsicheren festung
war spektakulär gescheitert
schließlich hat der alptraum für
gefangene und wörter ein ende der
supreme court von west virginia kommt zu
dem schluss dass das gefängnis nicht
mehr zweckdienlich ist und stellt den
betrieb
1995 ein
heute ist der verlassene gebäude komplex
ein mekka für esoteriker und
geisterjäger
das gefängnis gilt als verfluchter ort
eines der am häufigsten gesprochenen
übernatürlichen phänomenen ist eine
figur namens phänomen schattenmann
2004 gelang es einer frau namens paula
ein foto von ihr zu schießen sie sah
eine gestalt auf sich zukommen und
machte ein bild von ihr genau vor dieser
tür da stand der schattenmann und sah
sie an
[Musik]
das gefängnis markt seine schlimmsten
tage hinter sich haben aber es liefert
bis heute stoff für schauergeschichten
am rande von kubas hauptstadt havanna
finden sich rätselhafte spuren einer
turbulenten vergangenheit
[Musik]
inmitten dieser üppigen grünen
tropenlandschaft tauchen plötzlich
terrakotta farben formen zwischen den
palmen auf
sie sind nicht rechteckig sie sind alle
unterschiedlich als würden sie sich an
die landschaft anschmiegen sie sind
organisch fließend und es scheint keinen
richtigen eingang zu geben
die gebäude sehen fantastisch aus irgend
jemandes vorstellungskraft ist hier
aufgeblüht und hat diese freien formen
und designs hervorgebracht
eine sache fällt besonders ins auge
der erbauer scheint sich viele gedanken
gemacht zu haben wie das ganze auf die
menschen wirkt die dadurch gehen
feind ist dass es auf diesem gelände
nahezu keine rechten winkel gibt man
findet nur kurven und fragt sich was
wohl hinter der nächsten biegung liegt
warum ist dieser seltsame ort entstanden
und was hat er mit der kubanischen
revolution zu tun
an vielen stellen sieht man den verfall
die natur hat sich das gelände zum teil
zurück geholt und dann gibt es einige
bereiche die aussehen als wären sie
niemals fertig geworden
es scheint als hätte irgendetwas ganz
plötzlich die bauarbeiten unterbrochen
und man fragt sich warum die arbeiten
einfach eingestellt wurden es war doch
alles so vielversprechend aus
[Musik]
die ursprünge der anlage reichen bis in
die 60er jahre zurück
eine zeit des aufruhrs und der umbrüche
in kuba
obwohl der bau als orte einkehr und ruhe
dienen soll entsteht er inmitten einer
revolution
in den 50er jahren errichtete
staatspräsident fulham battista in kuba
eine diktatur und herrschte über ein
vollkommen korruptes land doch eine
gruppe von revolutionären sagte der
regierung den kampf an
fidel castro und sein comandante ernesto
che guevara führen die revolutionäre an
gemeinsam werden sie kuba und auch
dieses gelände für immer prägen
ende 1958 hatten sie die battista armee
besiegt castro verstaatlichte alle
ausländischen industriebetriebe alle
großen fabriken und selbst kleinere
geschäfte verschonte er nicht er baute
einen durch und durch kommunistischen
staates auf die kubaner sein castro
anfangs als revolutionär als eine
romantische figur seine wahre natur
erkannten sie noch nicht
erst mit der zeit wird der diktator
castro sein wahres gesicht zeigen
während das sozialistische kuba im
kalten krieg den weltfrieden aufs spiel
setzt nach der blutigen revolution
schwappt aber zunächst eine welle des
optimismus durch das kriegs gebeutelte
land
1961 trafen sich fidel castro und che
guevara zu einer runde golf in ein nobel
club früher war ihnen der zutritt dort
verwehrt gewesen
sie fanden es war eine schande dass die
meisten kubaner dort nicht hinein
durften und beschlossen das zu ändern
also schmiedeten sie den ehrgeizigen
plan den golfclub komplett umzukrempeln
und in etwas ganz anderes zu verwandeln
was haben die revolutionäre mit der
anlage vor
und warum muss der architekt am ende aus
kuba flüchten
castro bat den jungen kubanischen
architekten ricardo porro das gelände
neu zu gestalten und er baute eine reihe
von gebäuden die verschiedene zwecke
erfüllen sollten
dies ist das instituto superiore der
alte kubas staatliche kunsthochschule in
den fantasievollen bauten sollen
studenten wie schönen künste wie ballett
film musik und schauspiel erlernen
das war die geburt einer idee und man
darf nicht vergessen dass kunst für
revolutionäre und kommunisten sehr
wichtig war denn die kunst diente der
revolution
der einheimische cross sevillas oberon
hat hier einst bildhauerei studiert
ich habe 1966 mein studium begonnen für
einen kunstbegeisterten jungen wie mich
war das als würde ich eine neue welt
entdecken
ricardo bekommt nur zwei monate zeit für
die entwürfe der architekt stellt zwei
freunde ein die ihm helfen sie heißen
vittorio garantie und roberto colautti
die beiden jungen architekten stecken
viel herzblut in die baupläne ihre
inspiration ziehen sie aus dem wandel
den sie miterleben
wenn man durch die gänge spaziert
verliert man total das gefühl dafür
woher man kommt oder wohin man geht das
war auch die botschaft die die
architekten vermitteln wollten kuba
hatte seine geschichte hinter sich
gelassen und war nun dabei eine neue
zukunft zu gestalten
jedes gebäude ist einzigartig
aber allen ist ein gestalterischer kniff
gemeinsam der die bauzeit verkürzt und
fließende formen schafft das
katalanische gewölbe beim katalanischen
gewölbe platziert man zunächst einen
ziegelstein trägt schnell trocknenden
zement auf und lebt dann einen stein auf
den anderen und dann noch einen und noch
einen weil das alles schnell fest wird
braucht man kein schall gerüst
nach nur einem jahr öffnet die
kunsthochschule trotz noch laufender
bauarbeiten ihre tore
als die studenten kamen war das noch
eine baustelle sie hatten im clubhaus
unterricht oder draußen das war ein sehr
familiäres miteinander und die
kunsthochschule war in aller munde
die studenten machten musik für die
bauarbeiter hoffnung und vorfreude auf
die zukunft lagen in der luft
diese umgebung hat die einbildungskraft
beflügelt und eine art magische
arbeitsatmosphäre geschaffen doch schon
bald gerät der campus in eine krise der
sowjetische einfluss auf kubanern zu
und damit auch die politischen
spannungen zwischen den usa und der
sowjetunion die
usa empfanden castros freundschaftliches
verhältnis zu den russen als bedrohung
das ging so weit dass die welt 1962 in
der kuba krise an den rand eines
atomkrieges rückte
nach der kuba krise war das land
gezwungen die verteidigungsausgaben zu
priorisieren plötzlich hatte die
kunsthochschule ein geldproblem
hier stärker sich die kubanische
regierung der sowjetunion zuwendet desto
mehr kopiert sie auch deren funktionalen
architektur stil
es gab viel kritik von den russen an der
kunsthochschule und auch von den
kubanern selbst die sie für rückständig
hielten
was anfangs als mutiges experiment und
ausdruck künstlerischer freiheit gesehen
wurde galt nun als elitär und dekadent
schließlich werden die bauarbeiten
eingestellt und die hochschule sich
selbst überlassen
die bauarbeiter wurden abgezogen die
architekten entlassen und die schule
wurde sich selbst überlassen bei der
ballettschule fehlte sogar noch der
boden
für die architekten kommt es jetzt
knüppeldick
sie werden als staatsfeinde gebrandmarkt
und das bauministerium startet eine
hetzkampagne gegen sie
der leitende architekt porto hatte über
jahre mit herz und seele an diesem
projekt gearbeitet
er war am boden zerstört und verließ
kober schließlich um in europa zu leben
vittorio garantie wurde später der
spionage bezichtigt kam ins gefängnis
und musste kuba schließlich verlassen
jahrzehntelangen stehen die meisten
gebäude leer und verfallen
für studenten wie host wia zu brawn wird
die schließung der kunsthochschule bis
heute nach
ich bedauere dass diese phase der
kubanischen kultur in den 60ern so
abrupt endete
das war eine ära der aufbruchstimmung
der romantik der träume und der hoffnung
heute erlebt die hochschule einen
zweiten frühling und die anspruchsvolle
architektur erhöht die anerkennung die
sie verdient
in den 90er jahren wurden architekten
von außerhalb kubas auf die anlage
aufmerksam
sie erkannten die kreativität die da
drin steckt
viel zukunft sieht vielversprechend aus
auch wenn das projekt bislang nicht
fertiggestellt wurde könnte es sein dass
es mit fördergeldern aus europa zu ende
gebracht wird
im norden frankreichs 100 kilometer von
paris entfernt sind seltsame höhlen in
den fels geschlagen
[Musik]
an manchen stellen sieht dieser ort
geradezu fantastisch aus aber das ist
nur ein teil dieser verblüffenden anlage
ein unerwartetes geheimnis ist hier
verborgen
[Musik]
du läufst dort an einem sonnigen
sommertag rum und kommst dann an einen
eingang zu einer unterirdischen welt
man wird förmlich reingezogen in ein
gewirr von felsen schmalen pfaden und
tunneln hier und da wachsen bäume aus
den tunneln heraus als würden sie
flüchten wollen
im inneren der anlage liegen kalte
stille höhlen
man gerät ins staunen wenn man darunter
geht und diese großen stein korridore
und kammern sieht und die dunklen gänge
die in alle richtungen abzweigen
inschriften zeugen von vergangenen tagen
überall finden sich verstreute hinweise
eingravierten namen daten zeichnungen
und figuren
möglicherweise war das eine art
gefängnis um dort menschen einzusperren
in der nähe des eingangs ist eine
inschrift die hilft das rätsel zu lösen
da ist ein bildnis der göttin athene in
kampfausrüstung und darunter steht gehe
niemals hier durch das ist ein hinweis
worum es dort wirklich ging
was sollten diese räume abhalten oder
wen
der geheimnisvoller ort gewinnt im
neunzehnten jahrhundert an bedeutung als
die französische hauptstadt in neuem
glanz erstrahlen soll
zu der zeit war paris ein drecksloch es
war schmutzig überall grassierten
krankheiten und kriminalität die stadt
versank in laster und sünden
man wollte paris so umbauen dass es eine
würdige hauptstadt abgab zu diesem zweck
sollten breite boulevards und straßen
entstehen und um eine ganze stadt neu zu
errichten brauchte man jede menge
baumaterial da kam dieser ort ins spiel
dies sind die steinbrüche von montigny
in den lagerstätten wird
jahrhundertelang kalkstein abgebaut
bis dort plötzlich eine neue funktion
bekommt der einheimische eric beau
schneeweiß wie der abbau von statten
ging
anhand der schnitte im fels lässt sich
herleiten was für ein werkzeug benutzt
wurde hier sieht man die bogenförmigen
einkerbungen die die arbeiter mit ihren
spitzhacken hinterlassen haben
der abbau war nicht leicht alles wurde
per hand gemacht man fing oben an und
meißelte einen quader stein nach dem
anderen heraus bis das loch immer größer
und größer wurde es gab keinerlei
mechanische werkzeuge nur harte
körperliche arbeit
verborgen in der dunkelheit liegen noch
weitere spuren aus der vergangenheit
in einigen gängen finden sich überreste
aus einem der tödlichsten kriege des
zwanzigsten jahrhunderts
überall sind spuren von chlor und
inschriften an den wänden sie stammen
aus den jahren 1914 bis 1918 dieser ort
war offenbar ein schauplatz des ersten
weltkriegs
im september 1914 sind die deutschen
streitkräfte bis nordfrankreich
vorgerückt nach der ersten schlacht an
der narren ziehen sich französische und
britische truppen in das gebiet um den
steinbruch von montigny zurück
die deutschen marschierten auf paris zu
aber die briten und die franzosen
konnten den vorstoß aufhalten was dann
folgte war charakteristisch für die zeit
von 1914 bis 18 der grabenkrieg
für die truppen und der front sind die
tage hart und entbehrungsreich
eines setzt den soldaten auf beiden
seiten besonders zu
die artillerie tötete die meisten männer
in diesem krieg wer den artillerie
geschossen entkommen wollte musste sich
ein graben und durch zufall kam die
frontlinie in der nähe des steinbruchs
zum stillstand
im ersten weltkrieg drehte sich alles um
artillerie um feuerkraft die bomben
explodierten über einem mann antwortete
mit geschützfeuer das besondere an
diesem ort war dass man hier schutz fand
denn über einem war solider fels
die unterirdische anlage die einst
baumaterial für paris geliefert hat
trägt nun dazu bei die hauptstadt zu
verteidigen
die französische armee machte sich die
riesigen räume zu nutzen
sie besetzte dem gesamten steinbruch und
der ist riesig
als zu spitzenzeiten waren zwischen 200
und 500 soldaten im steinbruch und
seiner umgebung stationiert
unterirdische schutzräume spielten im
ersten weltkrieg eine wichtige rolle in
manchen wurden hauptquartiere
krankenhäuser lagerstätten oder sichere
quartiere für die soldaten errichtet
es war der letzte ort den die männer
sahen bevor sie an die front geschickt
wurden und der erste wenn sie von der
front zurück kamen da müssen sich
verschiedenste emotionen vermischt haben
die reliefs und inschriften zeugen vom
harten kriegsalltag
[Musik]
die männer die ihr tage oder wochenlang
stationiert waren mussten sich irgendwie
beschäftigen die frontlinie war nicht
weit entfernt sie waren umgeben von tod
und so lenkten sie sich für eine weile
ab
ein bereich in diesem distrikt kultur im
park sticht besonders hervor
dies ist die alte kapelle die von einem
soldaten namens leopoldo shell im
dezember 1914 erbaut wurde
dass diese kapelle sollte den männern
hoffnung geben die hier ausharren
mussten man darf nicht vergessen dass es
etliche tote zu beklagen gab viele der
männer wussten nicht ob sie am nächsten
tag lebend wieder kehren würden
deshalb brauchten sie einen platz zum
beten und um ihre morales leben
[Musik]
für die soldaten ist die gefahr
allgegenwärtig die schützengräben liegen
praktisch direkt vor ihrer haustür sie
wissen dass die deutschen früher oder
später auch den steinbruch angreifen
werden
auch die deutschen hatten eigene
steinbrüche und unterirdische anlagen
sie haben ingenieure beauftragt tunnel
hinter die feindlichen linien zu graben
um dort sprengstoff zu platzieren
die franzosen mussten ständig damit
rechnen dass die deutschen aus den
wäldern oder aus geheimen tunnel heraus
angriffen mit diesen ängsten mussten sie
leben nach vier jahren des
kräftezehrenden stellungskrieg kommt es
1918 zum durchbruch um die verhärteten
fronten aufzubrechen wänden beide seiten
neue methoden man aber was passiert
dabei mit den soldaten im steinbruch von
montigny
im frühjahr 1918 startet die deutsche
armee ihre letzte große offensive im
ersten weltkrieg sie setzt auch der
trügerischen ruhe im steinbruch von
monte nie ein ende
neue technologien und taktiken kamen zum
einsatz um die frontlinie zu
durchbrechen
man startete mit einem massiven
bombardements gefolgt von einem
infanterie angriff
deutschen sucht nach einem einfalls
punkt als sie ihn gefunden hatten ließen
sie nicht locker und kämpften sich bis
ins innere des komplexes durch
noch heute sieht man in den höhlen die
spuren des angriffs
gab es offensichtlich eine explosion
aber die kam nicht von draußen sondern
von innen
hier vorne sehen wie riesige blöcke die
heruntergestürzt sind nirgendwo sonst im
steinbruch ist so etwas zu finden
offenbar gab es eine große explosion um
die deutschen aufzuhalten
doch die franzosen können die deutsche
attacke nicht stoppen ihnen bleibt
nichts anderes übrig als den rückzug
anzutreten
eine unterirdische anlage wie diese ist
schwer zu verteidigen
sie ist zwar ein guter rückzugsort aber
sobald der feind durchbricht muss man
sie evakuieren
die franzosen mussten sich zurückziehen
die deutschen haben gas eingesetzt und
den steinbruch bombardiert
ein rückschlag für die franzosen und
ihre verbündeten doch sie haben einen
plan und schon einen monat später wird
der krieg vorbei sein
die deutschen wurden müde ihr vorstoß
hatte nur begrenzten erfolg der angriff
versandete langsam und kam schließlich
zum stillstand
die franzosen holen sich den steinbruch
und das umliegende gelände zurück der
kriegsschauplatz kommt endlich zur ruhe
etwa 10 km entfernt wurde der
waffenstillstand von pioneer
unterzeichnet all das blutvergießen und
all die gräuel des krieges fanden dort
ihr ende
nach dem ersten weltkrieg knüpft der
steinbruch von montigny an seine
vergangenheit an
der steinbruch ging wieder in betrieb
die menschen kehrten zurück und fanden
hier ein zuhause die häuser die dort
stehen zeugen von einer langen tradition
die bis zu den anfängen des steinbruchs
vor 300 jahren zurückreicht die letzten
bewohner sind erst in den 70er jahren
weggezogen und das was man dort sieht
war ihr zuhause
mitten in england in stoke on trent roth
ein schlafender gigant
[Musik]
eine ansammlung von bauten sticht aus
der landschaft hervor man sieht diese
schönen backsteinhäuser alte pipelines
hohe türme pumpanlagen und überall
verstreute stein und beton reste
komplex ist wirklich eindrucksvoll diese
ganzen gebäude müssen irgendwann mal
viel geld gekostet haben wahrscheinlich
gab es dort eine art boom doch
irgendetwas muss dann ziemlich schnell
ziemlich schief gelaufen sein
im innern der boden finden sich hinweise
auf ihre ursprüngliche funktion
das war ganz offensichtlich ein riesiger
industriebetrieb der im großen stil
produziert und hunderte oder tausende
beschäftigte hatte die sich alle
derselben sache widmeten
heute wirkt der ort traurig und
verlassen die natur holt ihn sich
langsam zurück
sind verlassen eisenbahnwaggons und ein
riesiger schornstein der darauf hinweist
was das für eine anlage war
offenbar wurde hier etwas wertvolles
hergestellt etwas für das sich der
enorme aufwand gelohnt hat eine so
weitläufige anlage zu bauen
die anlage entstand im neunzehnten
jahrhundert um die region north star
pitcher wirtschaftlich nach vorne zu
bringen
ziel war es die bodenschätze der
umliegenden ländereien zu gewinnen und
zu geld zu machen
da lagen große reichtümer vor der tür
die man sich nur nehmen musste aber das
war nicht so einfach viele menschen
setzten dabei ihr leben aufs spiel
welche bodenschätze hier unter der erde
liegen ist mit bloßem auge nicht zu
erkennen
lokalhistoriker nigel smith weiß worum
es geht
dies ist städte die mit viert ein
kohlebergwerk das den rohstoff gewann
der damals das ganze land am laufen
hielt
[Musik]
pole war die grundlage für alles zum
beheizen der häuser für handel und
industrie kohle befeuerte die wirtschaft
und somit auch den wohlstand
das kohlerevier north africa zählte zu
den produktivsten der erde von den
bergwerken in der region ist chatterley
whitfield lange zeit das
leistungsstärkste es hat die meisten
beschäftigten um die höchste förderrate
in ganz england zu spitzenzeiten waren
dort 5000 leute beschäftigt von den 4000
unter tage arbeiteten
die arbeit im bergwerk ist
lebensgefährlich
1937 kommt es zu einem folgenschweren
unfall
es gab mehrere fördertürme aber dieser
hier der hesse war der erste in
großbritannien der eine million tonnen
verkaufsfähige kohle produziert hat
nach heutigen maßstäben entspricht das
einem wert von 55 millionen euro
das geschäft mit dem schwarzen gold ist
hochprofitabel
doch um die kohle in den pfützen
abzubauen benötigen die betreiber
spezielle maschinen und mutige
bergarbeiter
we need war mit 17 jahren zum ersten mal
unter tage
am anfang fand ich es furchtbar die
dunkelheit der lärm sobald du ein
geräusch ist guckst du dich um und
fragst dich woher kommt das wenn man ein
knacken hört denkt man die decke bricht
gleich ein
über die jahrzehnte kommen immer wieder
bergmänner in lebensbedrohliche
situationen
ich habe gesehen wie einer umkam vier
befreiten sein gesicht von dem schott
darunter gekommen war sie hatten zu viel
zement in die schächte gepumpt um die
seitenwände zu verstärken wir konnten
gerade noch rechtzeitig abbauen ihr uns
alles um die ohren flog die steinbrocken
erwischten ihn und er war sofort tot wir
trugen ihn dann raus ein
lebensgefährlicher job
trotzdem gefahren muss die produktion
weiterlaufen
das land ist auf die kohle angewiesen
der schlimmste unfall hat sich 1881
ereignet berichten zufolge ist unter der
erde ein feuer ausgebrochen und außer
kontrolle geraten dabei hat sich
methangas entzündet und es gab eine
riesige explosion
24 männer kamen ums leben ihre leichen
liegen bis heute unter der erde
in rund 150 jahren kommen 4500 kumpel im
kohlerevier vom auf historische ums
leben als 1939 der zweite weltkrieg
ausbricht spitzt sich die lage für die
bergleute weiter zu
während des zweiten weltkriegs
explodierte die nachfrage nach kohle
regelrecht man brauchte sie dringend für
die rüstungsindustrie die
munitionsfabrik für die kasernen und die
häuser der soldatenfamilien die
kohleproduktion liefen unter absolutem
hochdruck
die zeche mussten noch produktiver
werden alles sollte mit vollgas laufen
neue infrastruktur wurde angeschafft
moderne brechanlage unterirdische gleise
ein netzwerk von rohren und tiefe tunnel
die britische kriegswirtschaft hängt am
tropf der kohle was den deutschen wohl
bewusst ist
wusste wie abhängig die briten von der
kohle waren vor allem die munitions
produktion daher wollte er die britische
kohleindustrie um jeden preis außer
gefecht setzen
stoke-on-trent wurde zum strategischen
ziel für die deutschen sie wussten um
die enorme produktionsleistung der
gegend und wollten ihre industrien
zerstören
die deutschen bombenangriffe ob
stoke-on-trent waren verheerend und
führten zu einem beinahe stillstand der
industrie
doch der luftwaffe gelingt es nicht das
bergwerk zu zerstören
mit derzeit laufen günstigere
alternativen der kohle den rhein hat
die strategische bedeutung des öls nahm
zu und großbritannien wurde abhängig von
lieferungen aus seinem kolonialreich und
dem nahen osten
1946 wurden noch 90 prozent der
elektrizität in großbritannien mit kohle
erzeugt
mitte der siebziger jahre ist der anteil
wesentlich geringer
die zeit der kohle war vorbei
das bergwerk wird unrentabel und muss
seine tore
1977 schließen
doch die kohleindustrie will sich ihrem
schicksal nicht widerstandslos fügen der
streit um die kohle eskaliert
das war zweifellos die bitterste
auseinandersetzung in der britischen
wirtschaftsgeschichte und tatsächlich
wirkt der konflikt bis heute nach
der streik 1985 war furchtbar der eine
oder andere ist zur arbeit gegangen aber
es waren hunderte streikposten darum sie
zu stoppen
es kam zu gewaltsamen
auseinandersetzungen zwischen den
streikenden und der polizei schließlich
endete der streit mit einem sieg der
konservativen regierung viele zeichen
wurden dicht gemacht damit war der
untergang der britischen kohleindustrie
besiegelt
jetzt stehen die schacht fördermaschinen
von sherwood hielt still den männern die
hier einst unter tage geschuftet haben
wird das bergwerk immer in erinnerung
bleiben
die kameradschaft war großartig und die
erinnerung daran haben wir uns bewahrt
heute sind viele der bauten vergessen
und verlassen manche ruinen erinnern an
dunkle zeiten andere waren einst
leuchtende beispiele für technologischen
fortschritt und hoffnung stille zeugen
von erfindungsreichtum
unternehmungsgeist und tatendrang
[Musik]